when you're saying that the
homunculus it's a it's a foolish model
in some ways
what about global workspace theory as
far as i understand i don't know much
about it i just
had a cursory glance at it it sounds
like there's a homunculus because
there's something that's viewing
or there's a well you can explain it
much better than i but what are you what
are your views on the global workspace
theory
so the global workspace theory is one of
the sort of most popular theories in
consciousness science
neuroscientific theories these days and
it's um
it's first developed by bernie bars and
and
taken on mainly by stan dehayne in paris
neuroscientist
and it makes a very simple sort of uh
proposal that
what we are conscious of the contents of
our consciousness
they become conscious in virtue of being
broadcast in this
workspace in the brain that gives them
access
to many different cognitive processes
which is why
i'm conscious of this glass of water
means
i can do many things now in virtue of
being
conscious of it i can drink it i can tip
it over the computer i can take it to
the kitchen
i can put it down again drink from it
i can talk about it um and so that
uh whatever in my brain is representing
the perception of that glass has
access to all these different flexible
cognitive processes
and for global workspace theory it's
that process
of being available broadcasted around
this
workspace that endows that perception
with the property of being conscious
um the analogy i think it's done it
again uses the analogy fame in the brain
for that theme in the brain fame in the
brain
so something becomes feminist famous
within the brain
all other parts of the brain know about
it suddenly my my
auditory cortex knows about it my
language senders know about it my motor
cordx knows about it it's famous there's
a cup there's a there's a glass of water
hooray everybody can see it it's famous
yeah
and that fame in the brain underwrites
conscious perception
um so that's that's the claim
the nice thing about it is it explains a
lot of the
functional properties we associate with
consciousness because indeed there are
things i can do when i'm conscious of
something that i can't when i'm not yes
and this flexible action is is central
to that
it's also testable because you can put
people in brain scanners
and change present them with stimuli and
vary whether they're consciously
perceived or not and you can look for
is there this ignition of this global
workspace in the in the brain
when they're conscious and many
experiments would say there is
the issue with it is that
it's not for me explaining a great deal
about
and back where we and as we sort of
begin to wrap up we're back where we
started which is with phenomenology
so the fact that something is famous in
the global workspace
explains a lot about what we can do
behaviorally and functionally
but it doesn't really explain to me at
least well why is it
why is this visual experience the way it
is the phenomenology of this visual
experience has a character
just being famous in the global
workspace doesn't really explain that
it also is not going to address the hard
problem of consciousness yeah that's
what i'm
thinking no one would no one claim that
it is but there's this often inverse
relationship
it has a benefit of being eminently
testable
um and although you know you can finesse
and say well
the global work space is wherever you
find it in the brain and there are
problems because
how do i separate the signature of a
workspace being active from simply my
consciously reporting something has
happened um
you know maybe the difference i'm seeing
in the brain is just the difference in
my verbal report rather than the
mechanisms that give rise to the
experience
so there are some tough questions there
too but it's
it's uh it's an appealing theory i you
know
i don't focus on it because for me i
want to focus on what kinds of
mechanisms explain phenomenology and for
me the bayesian perspective is much
is much more interesting
you